[Musique]
un fond intox est avec vous Anthony
Saint-Léger bonjour bonjour et sur les
réseaux sociaux en pleine Coupe du Monde
un des internautes la sueurs des
supporters ukrainiens ont vandalisé des
affiches avec des tags nazis alors il
affirmation a circule depuis le 22
novembre essentiellement sur Twitter et
télégram et dans toutes les langues en
français en anglais et en arabe
principalement à l'image de ce tweet par
exemple qui affirme donc que des
supporters de football ukrainiens ont
été arrêtés au Qatar pour avoir répondu
des symboles nazis insalu nazi et une
moustache d'Hitler sur l'Aïd la mascotte
du Mondial 2022 au 14 provencerait cette
vidéo que l'on va découvrir ensemble
regarder une vidéo attribuée à Al
Jazeera la chaîne d'informations
qatari basée à Doha 50 secondes ou le
reportage évoque donc l'arrestation de
supporters le 20 novembre donc le jour
du match d'ouverture des supporters
Ukrainiens ivres à l'origine de ce type
de vandalisme
sur des affiches les publications sur
Twitter ont dépassé les 150 000 vues et
sur télégram les elle tutoie elle est
400 000 vues l'information qui a été
relayée par exemple par le compte
officiel Twitter de l'ambassade russe au
Royaume-Uni et qui a priori initialement
été publié par le compte le compte
télégram d'une chaîne d'une d'une
émission russe que l'on voit ici qui est
codirigé par un journaliste présentateur
vedette de Russia one d'une chaîne
d'État Vladimir zoloviev qui a lui aussi
publié cela sur son compte télégram
telegram pardon Vladimir zolovieve qui
est un fervent admirateur de Vladimir
Poutine que l'on voit ici et qui est
présenté comme l'un des propagandistes
du Kremlin malgré les apparences n'est
pas à l'origine de l'information
effectivement et c'est assez troublant
on va d'ailleurs le voir ensemble si
Vladimir Zolo vient s'en aller voilà
pour ce qui est de la ressemblance on va
voir effectivement à quel point c'est
frappant puisque on va reprendre le
reportage que je vous ai montré et puis
on va en regarder un autre qui n'a
absolument rien à voir vous allez voir
c'est sur les animaux mais c'est pour
vous montrer quoi pour vous montrer que
la charte graphique est exactement la
même vous avez ici le logo que l'on
retrouve exactement ici et regardez la
titraille c'est bon certains mots en
orange qui sont surlignées c'est
absolument semblable j'ai envie de dire
presque troublant jusqu'au générique de
fin que l'on peut revoir ici sur cette
vidéo également et qui est lui aussi
absolument semblable même logo même
titre rail même générique de fin donc
sauf que le reportage est absolument
introuvable sur la chaîne
qatari et pour cause il n'existe pas la
chaîne qui a dû faire d'ailleurs un
démenti à ce propos sur son compte
Twitter officiel et évoquez donc un faux
reportage et qui n'a jamais mentionné
une quelconque informations de ce type
un reportage donc et une information
montée de toutes effectivement et pour
le prouver on va procéder par étape
d'abord concernant les supporters
Ukrainiens il y a pour leur au Qatar pas
de supporters de l'équipe du crâne et
pour cause puisque l'Ukraine n'a pas été
qualifiée pour le Mondial elle a elle
s'est inclinée en juin dernier face au
pays de Galles et non pas présente
pendant la compétition l'image que l'on
a vu dans le reportage c'est et celle-ci
et une recherche d'image inversée nous
montre que cette image elle a déjà été
utilisée par un média russe en février
2022 février dernier donc rien à voir
avec le kata pour ce qui est maintenant
de l'arrestation des supporters qui est
évoqué dans le reportage on voit à un
moment une image qui montre un policier
sauf que grâce au travail de notre
confrère belge Brest Castle du média de
fact checking Knack il a pu enquêter sur
les uniformes mais vous voyez que
l'uniforme présentée n'a absolument rien
à voir avec ceux des forces de l'ordre
qui actuellement officie au Qatar enfin
pour ce qui est maintenant de la
mascotte et des affiches qui sont qui
auraient été vandalisés
une dizaine d'affiches selon la vidéo
pendant le match d'ouverture donc au
stage au stade Alva cela nous a pas été
confirmé par nos équipes sur place d'une
part et d'autre part quand
au logo en tout cas au slogan nazi que
l'on voit ici on a tout simplement
jamais exister et ça nous a été confirmé
notamment par ce qu'on appelle l'analyse
forintie qui permet de repérer les
manipulations graphiques dans une image
et vous voyez bien qu'à l'endroit du
logo ici et bien les différents filtres
montrent effectivement à des points de
compression et qui montrent donc qu'il y
a bien eu retouche à cet endroit là et
que le logo a tout simplement en tout
cas le slogan a tout simplement bel et
bien été ajouté un faux reportage donc
qui mêle à la fois des logos la charte
graphique d'un média existant des images
authentiques mais aussi des images
anciennes et des images
retoucher un procédé qui n'est
absolument pas inédit en ces 9 mois de
guerre en Ukraine maintenant et qui
colle en plus aujourd'hui on l'a vu très
très bien à l'actu et qui utilise une
fois de plus ce narratif russe qui a
d'ailleurs servi de d'éléments
déclencheur on va dire en tout cas de
prétexte déclencheur à la guerre en
Ukraine et qui lie ça narratif russe
nazi et ukrainien merci Anthony
Saint-Léger c'était un faux intox avec
Anthony rester avec nous